welcome to today's live webinar impact
of global viral surveillance on
diagnosed
tools presented by dr. Gavin Chloe head
of infectious disease research Abbott
Diagnostics
my name is Christy Jewell and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laborat and brought to you
by Abbott Diagnostics to learn more
about our sponsor please click on the
Abbott logo on the far left of your
screen
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or you can use
the ask a question box to let us know
you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker dr. Gavin
Chloe head of infectious disease
research at a Diagnostics
dr. kloor D graduated from the national
university of ireland galway where he
received his PhD in molecular biology
and a Bachelor of Science in
microbiology and zoology
he provides scientific leadership in the
areas of infectious disease Diagnostics
by leading groundbreaking clinical
studies in hepatitis and HIV as one of
the top experts in the field his
innovative research is changing the way
infectious diseases are being diagnosed
to help improve patient outcomes
for a complete biography on dr. Chloe
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. klauer T you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the kind
introduction and hello everybody today
we're going to talk about the impact of
global surveillance on diagnostic tools
I'm going to jump right in the mission
of our surveillance program is to keep
pace with viral diversity and emerging
strains that pop up around the world
we established genetically and
geographically diverse specimen panels
that are used in essay development and
regulatory submissions these are really
the bar that all of our tests must must
cross before they're able to go to
market also it enables our test to to
ensure that our tests detect diverse HIV
and hepatitis strains regardless of
where they're found or where the
infections were acquired
I like this slide because it shows that
you know Abbott's legacy in HIV
basically this these photographs show
the teams that developed the first ever
fda-approved HIV s and interestly
interestingly if you look at the bottom
picture the two people in the center
Robin Gutierrez and George Dawson are
still part of the team today that are
developing HIV and hepatitis and other
infections of these assays this slide
here further illustrates Abbott's legacy
and infectious disease again the bottom
you'll see in 1985 we launched the first
ever HIV assay and on the top and the
hepatitis line we actually launched the
first hepatitis B surface antigen assay
and significantly earlier in the early
70s but what's significant here is we
continue to innovate and don't rest on
our laurels so you can see all of the
different hepatitis and HIV assays and
versions of assays that have been
developed and launched throughout the
decades
if we talk about diversity we're going
to use HIV as an example of how genetic
diversity can impact viral diagnostics
and in this slide you see there have
been four separate zoonotic infections
or infections from our primate cousins
both chimpanzees and gorillas have led
to four different groups of HIV virus
for different types if you like that in
some ways are obviously very similar in
the disease but in genetically they can
be very different the group M infections
which came form the majority of the
global pandemic came from chimpanzees
but you can see that group p and group O
are very different the length of these
lines represents the amount of genetic
difference between these these strains
and in some regions of group O they're
only about 50% genetic identity to the
subtype B of group M which is the major
subtypes of form that infects people in
North America and northern Europe and
also bring your attention to the fact
that there are 45 other non-human
primate species so we have to be
continuously alert and aware of the fact
that other zoonotic transmissions may
occur and form a fresh through human
health
of looking at HIV more specifically
there are three major sources of genetic
diversity in for the HIV virus first
this virus replicates at a very high
level and it has an error-prone
replication process that does not
correct any mutations that may occur we
talked previously and they be previous
lied about the different starting point
so you have the different zoonotic
infections so there's a large amount of
difference in those starting points
finally the HIV virus can infect these
cells so different strains of HIV can
infect the same individual and in fact
they can infect the same cell if you get
different strains of HIV in the same
cells you see in this the bottom of this
slide we have HIV genome a and HIV
genome be in the same cell sections of
the nucleic acid can break off and
recombine so you get an additional
shuffling of the deck and you get a
recombinant virus that actually contains
a mosaic of the genetic material of the
two viruses present in the cell these
are becoming increasingly more common
and forming the majority of epidemics in
certain parts of the world
this slide illustrates the exceptional
genetic diversity of HIV and we look at
it in the context of other infections we
commonly hear about so if you look on
the left-hand side of this slide you've
got influenza h3n2 and this represents
all of the genetic diversity found
globally in 1996 of this influenza virus
on life decided we see one individual so
this is the amount of genetic diversity
found in one individual with HIV that is
longitudinally sampled over a few years
beside that in Amsterdam we see the
amount of genetic diversity in roughly
25 individuals this is a one time point
looking at sub they're also type B so
they're relatively close but on a scale
when you look at influenza they're
extremely diverse and I mean in the
Democratic Republic of Congo 196 samples
shown here on the right hand side
they're all group M so no group N or P
so they're all group M but they're not
also type B but again you see an immense
amount of genetic diversity that really
dwarfs the global influenza diversity
scene in 1996 it's a very challenging
pathogen to work with and develop robust
to for how does HIV stack up relative to
hepatitis B and hepatitis C on this side
you can see that Hep B has a similar
amount of genetic diversity to HIV but
hepatitis C actually dwarfs HIV which as
you saw the previous slide dwarfed
influenza so hepatitis C has a lot of
diversity have be similar to HIV but in
general these three viruses are a very
challenging group to work with
why do we care so much about this
genetic diversity particularly from the
diagnostic side you can see from this
slide on the right hand side if we think
about molecular assays their ability to
function relies on primers and probes
binding to specific sequences on the
virus genome and if you have mutations
on that viral genome that can impact the
ability of primers and probes to bind
and a PCR reaction to work and as a
result of the obtained
similarly the serology assays will
detect proteins or antibodies and these
are encoded by the DNA of the virus so
you can see well the antibodies aren't
encoded by the virus offices by the host
immune system but the proteins encoded
in the DNA can be impacted by mutations
which then can impact the ability of
serology assays to detect them
again looking more at a case as to why
this genetic diversity matters we see
here a report of the identification of a
group P infection from a 62 year old
woman who was from the Cameroon was
residing in France who was found to be
HIV positive and it was Western blot
confirmed when she arrived at Park in
Paris it was not detected by the viral
load assay that was being used at the
time that was a monitor 1.5 assay but it
was detectable and there was significant
viremia
when the avid real-time HIV assay was
used there's about four and a half to
five and a half logged copies per mil
maybe if there were several samples that
were archived that were tested and
explains the different numbers
importantly the Ovid architect HIV combo
assay was also positive when this site
tried to figure out what was going on
they suspected grubo and but it was not
possible to amplify the sample with
group O specific primers or group M
specific primers
it was successfully amplified in
sequence eventually and that was
identified as the first ever group P
infection in the world again we showed
that slide areas which indicated that
group P came from gorillas remark
originally what was important to note
about this slide is that both the Abbott
real-time and the architect assays were
not developed with group P in mind
because it didn't it wasn't known about
but it accurately both detected and
quantitated this virus the cause of the
way these assays are designed because of
our focus on global vowel diversity
so talk about the avid global
surveillance program more specifically
this program has been in place for over
25 years
focuses primarily on hepatitis and HIV
and other retroviruses and really it's
it was spawned from HIV group Oh as we
shown earlier Abbott had the first ever
fda-approved HIV assay and it worked
very well until group O came along and
then it didn't work quite as well
because the amount of genetic diversity
of group O so Abbott implemented the
global surveillance program to get ahead
of this and be proactive and to ensure
that we stay one step ahead of this
constantly changing epidemic as we
mentioned earlier we monitor the
emergence of new viral strains and we
establish well characterized panels that
are really used to challenge all of the
acids that we develop here at Abbott so
we keep an eye on what's happening in
the in the world to make sure that the
tests that we have on market are
functioning as they should and also that
the tests that we're developing will
continue to meet the challenge of that
evolving epidemic over the coming years
one interesting point is that this
program is extremely collaborative and
also outgoing if you like it is
indicated by the more than 125
peer-reviewed publications that have
come from this program and also the
amount of sequence as you know if you
publish you really have to upload the
sequence to GenBank so thousands of
these rare sequences have been uploaded
to GenBank to help other researchers and
help move the field forward
today's we've archived about 70,000
samples from 45 countries on six
continents so we're trying to really
sample the world as much as is possible
and these are the 70,000 kind of unusual
temples from unusual places
but this slide illustrates where the
global surveillance program has been and
if you you can imagine why we try to
sample the world you can't be everywhere
all the time so we take an approach of
like a rolling approach or roving
approach rather where we where we will
sample in specific locations and then
move around to try and sample others and
here we also go to areas of high
immigration like Paris or London or
Madrid to try and if you can't be
everywhere you can be where everybody is
going through at least trying to get an
idea of what's going on around the world
as you see this slide changing it shows
where we're currently working we've been
working a lot in asia-pacific recently
Central Asia born in West and Central
Africa a little bit in Europe too and
then as we move into the future we're
going to continue some of our work in
Asia the Indian subcontinent Africa and
will continue to move around the world
to try and understand how the epidemic
is is changing I'm going to illustrate a
little bit of our work and with an
example of India and this a
collaboration has a unique challenge
because usually we will get samples from
all of the world shipped to our
facilities here at Chicago and we'll do
the characterization here but you can't
get samples out of India so we've been
collaborating with Y or get on center
for AIDS research and education and
they're located in Chennai their
fantastic group of collaborators that
have a network all over India they
service at-risk high-risk populations
such as MSM and people who inject drugs
they they collect samples and we use the
leftover samples for our work and to
date we've looked at over a thousand
samples we've generated about 1300
sequences and what's been interesting is
that we found that a lot of the HIV and
hepatitis strains track with the drug
routes around India whether they're
coming from Asia or coming from
you know Afghanistan and I kind of
Indian Indian area or more towards the
European side so it's kind of
interesting to see how the virology
tracks with with these other epidemics
such as drug use and except and that
type of thing and the big program works
by initially screening with rapid tests
and then in the core lab you know HIV
combo is used or core antigen or auntie
HCV in the case of hepatitis C and then
viral load is performed in the central
lab and sequencing goes from there where
samples are have a high enough power
load for sequencing the Democratic
Republic of Congo is different in that
the samples again they can come to
Chicago and we've been working with
Carol MacArthur and the University
Protestant in Congo to get leftover
samples that are shipped to Chicago for
screening and sequencing of HIV Hep B
Hep C and hub Delta what was interesting
about the findings so far in Congo is
that we find a lot of subtypes so
subtype a c JK pure subtypes which in
many other parts of the world you don't
you don't find them very often and
finding pure subtypes like this is also
quite rare we also found a lot of
circulating recombinant forms that we
discussed earlier and are listed here in
a few unique were common forms too and
to take we've sequent we've received
about 5500 samples generated about 200
sequences and I think one of the key
take homes that we're going to be doing
more sequencing to get closer to a few
thousand sequences from Congo so they'll
have more to report shortly
in China again it's similar to India and
that samples can't come out of China but
we set up like some collaborations with
blood transfusion centers IBT in Chengdu
and the national center for clinical
laboratories in CCL in Beijing the one
of the studies with IBT looked at the
performance of CMIA versus e IA in the
transfusion space and found that one
CMIA performed better than one or two
CIA said better concordance of Western
blood gave lower false positives and
false negatives in addition we got these
samples and we also sequence many of
them we generally so far we've generated
834 sequences from 1,800 samples that
we've received and that's both from MTC
l and IB T and what's remarkable about
the Chinese samples is there's a lot not
a whole lot of diversity found there but
we did find some circulating with common
forms which are most commonly associated
with Africa in Shanxi Province and blood
donors from that problems was an
interesting find from this working
channel
Vietnam we're collaborating with the
blood transfusion services there to do
general surveillance and in addition
we're working with the Ministry of
Health and also the US CDC the w-h-o and
other stakeholders to conduct the
first-ever comprehensive viral hepatitis
C row survey of that country where
28,000 people will be screened and this
the collection has been conducted the
testing has been done on now the data
will be compiled and this is be very
useful for this country and the Ministry
of Health to develop plans to tackle
their viral hepatitis epidemic
others other
Liberation's which are ongoing at
different phases if you like include
work with the Pakistan transfusion
services that study is well underway the
samples have been collected and shipped
to Chicago for characterization in
Uganda with their blood transfusion
service that is starting off with
testing is beginning and samples are
being collected as we speak and then
maybe a we're in the earlier stages for
the logistics a lot of things
so 25 years of discovering rare and
emerging strains what here's a little
kind of some of the highlight reel of
that if you like so in 1994 the
surveillance program was initiated
looking primarily at HIV hepatitis B was
added in 2009 and in 2011 our
surveillance program identified the
second only the second case of HIV
groupie that has ever been discovered
was identified from our cohorts of
Cameroonian samples which we had in the
freezer so one we sample was first
identified by Simone in Paris from a
woman from Cameroon we decided to go
back into the archives samples of
Cameroon from Cameroon to look for group
P and in fact we found one case in 2014
Hep C was added to the surveillance
program and in 25 2015 a novel peji
virus was discovered in a Hep C positive
sample and this PG virus kind of cluster
is close to rat and bat PG virus was in
a woman who as I said was hepatitis C
positive it appears to be somewhat
associated with Hep C but we're still
trying to really tease apart the
clinical significance of this finding
and its association with hepatitis C in
2016 hepatitis Delta was added to the
surveillance program as was the novel
peji virus that we found because we
wanted to understand you know is this
PEGI virus found more broadly in the
world and hepatitis Delta is extremely
important as a co infection of hepatitis
B and so understanding its prevalence
globally and its diversity that is
extremely important from the public
health perspective again in 2017 a rare
htlv 3 only v ever case of htlv 3 was
identified in cameroon as was some
additional group n samples which are
very rare also and recently we've been
focusing a lot of effort to optimize and
develop next-generation
tech
weeks that form us a robust solution for
our surveillance program and we'll talk
a little bit about that in some
subsequent slides so here we see an
illustration of a before and after so
before 2015 our surveillance program was
carried out using traditional Sanger
sequencing so the subtype we would
sequence three different regions if we
wanted to get a whole genome we'd have
to do a lot more sequencing to fill out
that genome this process would take
about one to four weeks for a sample and
require about anywhere up to 35 PCR
reaction you had to really have some
prior knowledge of the strain you were
looking at and designing the appropriate
primers was extremely important after
2015 using universal NGS techniques with
universal HIV a random priming we were
able to multiplex 30 samples the
technique would take you know four days
one reaction per sample and had a
extremely good track record for getting
whole genomes from samples with low
viral load
here we see some of the outputs of that
is was published by Mary Rogers in
biology in 2017 we have five hundred and
twenty four diverse sequences sequence
using these next-gen methods and we're
able to get 98% coverage of group and
seat samples and 24 group o samples as
well which is remarkable 401 mostly
genotype a re sequences were generated
from heavy samples again with average of
84 percent coverage
htlv which is a very rare infection we
were able to get 80% coverage of the HDL
v3 which is only the fifth case ever
found of HDL v3 for HCV 103 sequences
they were mostly genotype four were
processed and primarily from older four
participants and this all these samples
came from Cameroon again with a high
degree of coverage for these samples
one method that's recently been
published by Mike Berg is called x-gen
and it's a universal target capture for
HIV and this uses the traditional NGS
approach but where the difference comes
in is Mike created thousands of probes
which were specific to HIV which then
enriched this sample and the pooled
libraries for HIV sequences and give a
much better success rate for getting
whole genomes and from low viral load
samples so here we see example of that
on the left hand side of the HIV group
subtype G sample revoir load about three
and a half logs and you can see the
smart approach more traditional NGS
approach at very low depth and had
reasonable coverage but using the
enrichment with x-gen you get almost
complete genome and very robust yet in
this sample again it's a very powerful
technique as you see on the right hand
side we're able to get almost whole
genomes from samples that have a
significantly lower viral loads than
using the traditional NGS techniques
with no enrichment even down to log
three and below you get a significant
amount of genome coverage where you
would have had a negative result without
this enrichment and above log 3.5 you
get almost whole genomes most of the
time and again this is without any prior
knowledge of what strain or sequence
you're dealing with
and also works for other viruses as
illustrated here on the top left you see
hepatitis B with and without this x-gen
approach of enrichment so you get almost
a whole genome for hepatitis B with no
prior knowledge of what you've got
relative to other sporadic coverage
without the x-gen coverage for hepatitis
Delta remarkable difference you get very
little coverage and depth without x-gen
but you get pretty much the whole genome
with xgn in this case and on the bottom
side these two panels show peji virus
and of the novel peji virus on the
left-hand side here you you can really
clearly see you get a whole genome
coverage and remarkable depth and on the
right-hand side where you had more
sporadic coverage you get almost whole
genome the baptism is great but you get
the whole genome and quite significant
depth as well so the impact of global
surveillance is significant we want to
we want to illustrate that and here we
have a case study of a woman who was
getting a kidney dialysis patient she
had been vaccinated it and in 2010 her
anti-hbs titer was 82 millions per mil
she was surface antigen negative in 2016
she was hospitalized and was tested and
surface antigen positive she hadn't been
dialyzed in a separate room or on a
separate machine between 2010 and 2016
and so this means that without knowing
when her she became positive and had a
vacuum breakthrough infection it's not
possible to know how many other people
were potentially exposed who were
dialyzed on in the same room and I'm the
same machinery in 2017 further analysis
revealed that her viral load was 14
million her surface a thps was 114
million she was positive by one test and
negative by another that positive test
was the architect the avid architect
test and when they did the sequencing
they found a common surface antigen gly
or
mutation requisition 11:45 and that the
authors did a subsequent survey and
found nine out of twenty three labs they
tested use methods that would not
commonly detect a surface antigen mutant
so this is a clear illustration of why
keeping an eye on mutants are is
important for hepatitis B this study
published our case study published by
Hendrix Adelle and I'm from New York it
was there and is it the indication if
you like us too
whyever pays so much attention to this
this topic interesting to note that this
case was found I believe it was Nebraska
or that part of the United States of
Central America not a central United
States on Central America I'm sorry but
not in a high immigrant population such
as in New York or Chicago or Miami so
found in in middle America
another impact for the surveillance
program here more of a public health one
with the identification of a new
hepatitis B genotype I in Thailand this
had only previously been shown in China
and Vietnam and you can see in the
bottom panels you see a clear break
point where you you have a recombination
and the closer's with genotype see but
is distinctly different it is a novel
genotype so this shows that the this is
becoming more pervasive around this part
of Southeast Asia and China important
from a public health perspective as we
can see in this slide as an example of
how our surveillance program is put into
action and you can see the performance
of a host of different assays including
our current on market surface antigen
qual assay as as well as our
next-generation surface antigen next
qualitative assay and the relative
performance of these two tests in very
diverse and samples that contain
surface antigen escape mutants and you
can see on the top line our
next-generation surface antigen test is
performing quite well and outperforming
our existing assay and that of some of
our comparators type 2 HIV
you know what about the US this study
was performed between 2011 2004 and 2011
and it's interesting that in this time
frame people really thought that the
North American epidemic was all subtype
B group M sub type B but this
collaboration with a RUP looked at the
sequence of samples that went through
this reference laboratory over this time
and found that there was about three
point two seven percent were non B
strains and this was sampled from 37
states and it also Illustrated that the
prevalence of non B strains including a
lot of circulating recombinant forms as
you can see from this slide was
increasing between 2004 and 2011 by 2011
that had gone up from three point two
seven percent to four point one to
percent and as continues to increase to
this day so I think obviously you can
see the diversity is high in Texas
California Miami and around the Chicago
in the Midwest area and up in New
England as well
so in our surveillance program in Africa
we have focused a lot on Central and
West Africa in particular in Cameroon
has been a very productive and fertile
area for looking at genetic diversity
and the reason for that is its proximity
to non-human primates particularly
non-human primates where simian gorilla
gorilla and chimpanzee simian
immunodeficiency virus or the perversion
of HIV has been found so you can see the
collection sites are all in South
Cameroon and there's many non-human
primates colonies and many of them do
Harbor these infections so we've been
working there since 2011 and actually
the sides a bit dated because we're
still working there so 2011 to 2019 and
at these sites 22 sites in total they
collect about 6 mils of blood they turn
that into into plasma it collected at
voluntary testing campaigns antenatal
clinics it's collected from patients who
present with illness of unknown etiology
or by door-to-door recruitment and
annually we receive about 3,000 samples
2 to 3,000 samples as part of the study
and we get about anywhere from 1 to 3
mils sometimes a 1 mil sample can be
quite challenging particularly if you
find something interesting that's not a
lot of volume to work with and to date
with more than 14,000 samples collected
and screams actually that's getting
closer to probably 18,000 now some of
the major findings that we've attributed
to this collaboration has been the
finding of group MN & O samples we find
that in this part of Cameroon there's
about 10% hepatitis B prevalence and 15%
of those escaped our possess escaped
mutations to surface antigen htlv is
found at about 1% and again this is the
collaboration where we found only the
fifth
ever case of htlv 3 globally and again
we do upload sequences to GenBank so
about a thousand sequence
have been uploaded to GenBank from this
collaboration alone
we've also been leveraging this
longitudinal data and this archive of
samples to understand the prevalence of
viruses more epidemiological work and in
Cameroon we looked at samples collected
who are hepatitis B positive over those
years and we have about 1,900 samples
with sufficient volume to screen for
hepatitis Delta again hepatitis Delta is
a virus that is very aggressive and if
you're positive for Delta it's poor
prognosis more rapid progression to
cirrhosis and cancer with a higher
mortality rate and what was shocking and
made us do a double-take is what we
looked at this data there was more than
45% of these B positives were Delta
antibody positive so if we think that
Cameroon has about 10% B in the samples
that we've collected and screened then
that would mean you've got almost 5% of
the population harbors that the Delta Co
infection and of those 35 percent were
viremic meaning this active replication
of the virus and these indications so
that's quite astounding and our findings
have recently been replicated or
validated if you like by a national
survey that was conducted by the
institut pasteur
we also sequenced all the samples that
were RNA positive with sufficient viral
load to get a sequence and we found a
wide variety from 1 to 8 we got several
we uploaded about a 300 whole genomes
and many many more similar number of
almost whole genomes so it significantly
increase the amount of sequence that's
available globally from hepatitis Delta
from this cryptic study we also looked
at hepatitis C from these from samples
we had in the freezer from Cameroon over
the years and the findings again were
remarkable and these were published in
2018 what we found was that the overall
prevalence of HCV by remiel with an RNA
si was about two and a half
percent this was significantly lower
than the percentages that have been
quoted to me before of a prevalence of
15% or 11% in Cameroon so we find that
the real number is more around two and a
half percent
we also found two interesting biases
that you like there was a definite bias
towards males so men were almost twice
as likely to be positive as women as you
can see in the top right-hand panel what
females were to 2% prevalence and males
were about 3.8 percent prevalence
we also found an age effect so although
most of the samples were collected from
people who were less than 40 years old
the vast majority of the HCV positive
infections were found in people who are
more than 40 years old this is important
from a public health perspective if
somebody wanted to try and tackle
hepatitis C in Cameroon they would do
well to tackle people who are over 40 or
over 50 and focus on men maybe in a
critical clinical setting and looking at
co-infections
40% of the HCV positives were also HIV
positive there was a not a lot of Hep B
co-infection about 3.6 percent of the
hit cities were or happy co-infected and
only about 14% had the edgy virus
antibody in their in their blood so this
would kind of lend you to think that
similar routes of transmission might be
at play in HIV and hepatitis C epidemic
in Cameroon and also again if you wanted
to stratify target populations to screen
and trees HIV catechol settings might be
a good place to go
looking at diversity as its effects
diagnostic test here Mary Rogers
published in 2018 the impact of
significant amounts of mismatches on the
Abbott real-time viral load assay and
what was remarkable we were able to see
that this assay was been incredibly
robust even to group P as we showed
earlier group and and various other
circulating recombinant forms that have
up to five or six mismatches to their
primers and probes the athlete is not
impacted and gives an accurate robust
result again also the architect assay
accurately detects all of these
extremely diverse samples validating the
importance and utility of this program
as I indicated earlier it's a very
collaborative and outward-looking
program and we published about 125
papers some of them are highlighted here
such as the identification of the second
group P infection in the world the
identification and discovery of the
novel Taiji virus Mike Birds next-gen
sequencing methods the x-gen methods and
others have been published so that
others can take advantage of those the
identification of the fifth case of htlv
three in cameroon we've also been doing
a lot of work looking at novel
biomarkers for hepatitis B as
illustrated by these paper by Emily
Butler looking at pre genomic or RNA
so the surveillance program works by
collaborating with labs and
investigators around the world who may
have access to unique cohorts or unique
patient specimens that maybe don't fit
the normal paradigm the Diagnostics
don't fit the clinical picture or
different diagnostic assays or giving
different results those are usually
interesting samples to take a look at
and trying to understand what's going on
obviously the samples are tested and
characterized with existing and novel
techniques anything that is discovered
is shared with our collaborators and
with the community through peer-reviewed
publications and personal communication
with collaborators and then novel any
novel strains are also published when we
when we find them and we as Ellis trated
in previous slides we are trying to help
local ministries of health or
stakeholders to understand their
epidemia RepA demyx on the local level
and all of this data really goes on to
fuel innovation both in the development
of novel novel tests or novel
applications or how these tests are used
in the field
and we're very proud and actually I'm
very privileged and proud to be part of
this program to be the one the only
company to have a viral surveillance
program of this scope and scale that's
this I would say collaborative and
transparent
our partnerships our money and as I said
they change over time we work in
numerous countries
published many peer-reviewed papers seek
uploaded more than 6,000 sequences to
GenBank and we've discovered many rare
and new strains of both HIV and
hepatitis and also new viruses so if
anybody on this call is interested in
collaborating or getting involved in
this please feel free to reach out and
contact us at global surveillance at
Abbott comm or contact your local rep
and they'll be able to put you in touch
with the right person and you'll end up
with me most likely I'd like to thank
our colleagues both within Abbott ID
Corps research at UCSF at the addict
virus discovery and Diagnostic Center
our external collaborators in Congo and
Cameroon are listed here NICUs code and
betas are kept to a dorm of any so and
also the collaborators around the world
and many of the other countries that
we've described today that brings our my
presentation to an end and with that I'd
like to open it up to the audience for
any questions
Thank You dr. claw ready for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for okay let's get started
with some great questions coming in dr.
Chloe let's start with this one what is
your view on the need to consider viral
diversity in developed countries I think
it's extremely important to consider
viral diversity
regardless where you are in developed
countries we're only a plane ride away
from anywhere in the world and it really
is a global village so with tourism with
you know military deployment with you
know immigration you don't really know
where viral infections have originated
or have been acquired so I think it's
incredibly important no matter where you
are in the world welcome developed and
developing countries
now dr. Corti does prior knowledge
suggest that divergence always comes
from Africa or developing areas no I
think you know it definitely depends on
the virus that we're talking about and I
think you'll see that in the case of HIV
you know it originated in in Central
West Africa and so there it's at the
longest history there and that it'd be
close proximity as we discussed to
potential new zoonotic infections does
Drive a lot of diversity there but the
virus is changing and evolving in
different ways in different parts of the
world and the the epidemic in Africa
looks very different than the epidemic
in Asia and in the US but there is
evolution and shuffling of the deck if
you're like globally
what do you expect the next generation
assays to accomplish that current ones
don't I think in the case of HIV and
hepatitis
there's a definite push to increase
sensitivity to diagnose people maybe in
the acute phase to make sure that in the
case of hepatitis B you've got a better
detection of a cold hepatitis B that
might go undetected there's the ever
presence needs to have robust detection
so again back to keeping pace with the
evolution of the virus to make sure that
we always detect those diverse strains
Thank You dr. kloor D and it looks like
we have time for one final question
where do you see future generations of
assays having most medical impact well I
think in the case of HIV they drive for
1990 92 WH o goal of detecting and
having a 90% of people who are HIV
positive knowing their status and then
90% of them on treatment of 90% of those
people successfully suppressed you know
it all starts with Diagnostics so I
think that's going to be a key focus you
need to identify the patient so that
they can be treated suppress prevent
further transmission the same is really
true in the viral hepatitis space where
now there's curative therapies and we
there's a a push to eliminate viral
hepatitis or hepatitis C in particular
you know by 2030 there's some very
aggressive WHR goals as well so
Diagnostics needs to be robust
everywhere that it's performed and it's
going to have varying modalities from
rapid tests to korolev and molecular so
it's definitely the diagnostic algorithm
is evolving as such as the virus thank
you dr. kloor d and thank you again for
your time today and your important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Abbott Diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions those
questions that we did not have time to
answer today and those submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand and labyrinth will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon have a great day
you